I believe that if you can learn to focus
on what you have you will always see
that the universe is abundant and you
will have more I believe you need to be
equally ambitious as you are grateful
I always felt grateful for even the
small things I always used to celebrate
the small things rise and shine it's an
spresso time good morning belief nation
it seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded on to the world so grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
keep a grateful journal over to you
Oprah Winfrey as I grown older I've
learned to appreciate living in the
moment and I ask that you do - I've
asked I'm asking this graduating class
those of you here I've asked all of my
viewers in America and across the world
to do this one thing keep a grateful
Journal every night list five things
that happened this day in days to come
that you are grateful for what it will
begin to do is to change your
perspective of your day and your life I
believe that if you can learn to focus
on what you have you will always see
that the universe is abundant and you
will have more if you concentrate and
focus in your life on what you don't
have you will never have enough be
grateful keep a journal you all are all
over my journal tonight gratitude is a
game changer for entrepreneurs it's a
game changer because it balances a scale
entrepreneur so often we are driven
we're ambitious we want more we want to
achieve more we want to go and
accomplish these huge things and that's
awesome but suddenly that strive to do
more to be more to be better often that
can come from a dark place when we don't
accomplish it we spiral down we get
depressed we get negative and so the
gratefulness helps
to scale I believe you need to be both I
believe you need to be equally ambitious
as you are grateful one of the practices
that I do with my team is I have a
private Facebook group and every morning
I'll post three things that I'm grateful
for and it might be some big thing it
might be like today as YouTube filming
day and I'm so excited to be here with
you and make these amazing videos for
this audience and sometimes it's
something like I'm grateful for the
clouds in the sky because it makes me
appreciate the Sun or I'm grateful for
Timo and his cuteness in his energy
level just finally three things out of
my life - to find the balance to balance
out that crazy ambition I think it's
really important that you have both and
so if I look at my youtube channel as an
example on the one hand I think that I
should be doing more I think that my
channel should have 10 million
subscribers that I should be having a
way bigger impact that I suck I think
that I suck I think that comparing
myself to a Tony Robbins or Les Brown
young Les Brown or an Eric Thomas or any
of these guys I feel like I suck and I
still have a long way to go to get
better and I'm working really hard to do
it and I think that I'm awesome I think
that my channel is awesome I think that
it deserves to have a Nobel Peace Prize
for this channel
I love the impact I love you guys and so
I hold both thoughts in my head at the
same time I have crazy ambition to want
to do more and I'm so grateful for
everything that I have right now I think
you need both because if you only have
the gratitude and the happiness then you
don't strive to do more and if you only
have the ambition then that can be a
really dark place because you're not
balanced for anything else so it's equal
parts gratitude and ambition together I
think that's really important balance
that I feel like a lot of entrepreneurs
don't have I feel like entrepreneurs too
often are carried way too much by the
ambition side and haven't brought up the
gratefulness enough now I've got some
special bonus clips for you but before
getting to that my question of the day
ties into Oprah's five things I want you
to write down in the comments below five
things that you are extremely grateful
for today leave it down I'm really
curious to see what you have to say
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
where it is much-loved enjoy the bonus
clips and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of an espresso
[Music]
attitude is one of the most strongest
forms of power and attracting good
things you know if you truly feel
grateful for the things in your life
I always felt grateful for even the
small things I always used to celebrate
the small things now I might be
celebrating the bigger things but I
always celebrate every little good thing
that would happen to me in my life even
before I had any kind of money or any
that I would celebrate and I would feel
grateful for it and it just gave me more
and this is exactly the same thing
that's happening right now I still
remain grateful and more comes what I
found you know 12 years of research
11,000 pieces of data I had I did not
interview and all that time a person who
would describe themselves as joyful or
describe theirs lives as joyous who did
not actively practice gratitude and for
me it was very counterintuitive because
I kind of went into the research
thinking that the relationship between
joy and gratitude was if you're joyful
then you should be grateful but it
wasn't that way at all it was really
that practicing gratitude invites Julie
entire lives and when I say practice I
think this is this is the part that
really changed my life it changed my
family and the way we live every day
when I say practice gratitude I don't
mean kind of like the attitude of
gratitude or feeling grateful
I mean practicing gratitude these folks
shared in common a tangible gratitude
practice they either kept gratitude
journals some of them did interesting
things like at 1 2 3 4 like at 12:30 for
every day they said something out loud
that they were grateful for they one of
the things that we do like we say grace
at dinner and so now after grace we go
around and everyone and my family says
something they're grateful for I mean
including what's interesting is when we
first started I have a first grader at
first grade son Charlie and 8th grade
daughter Ellen and at first I thought
and we've been doing for a couple years
now like they're like oh god mom and if
there was a little like this is you know
are you experimenting on us it's a
little bit of that but now what's
interesting
even after we did it for like a couple
of weeks that on those crazy busy nights
where we're trying to
like get to soccer and piano and
homework and Steve and I are just like
resuit we say a quick prayer we start
eating my kids are like whoa what are
you grateful for and it's been
extraordinary because not only
absolutely does it invite more joy into
our house it also is such a soulful
window into what's going on in my kids
lives you know so there's some days
where my eighth grader I'll be like I'm
joyful that there's a huge thick wall
between my room and my brother's room
you know something he's very you know
honest but there other day she'll say
you know she had a friend whose mother
recently died and she said you know for
a month she would say I'm just so
grateful that y'all are healthy right
now you know and so not only did it make
us all more aware of what we had and
more willing to slow down and really be
thankful for the joyful moments we had
but it let me know where she was
emotionally in her life you know my side
is always yeah I'm grateful for bugs I'm
grateful for frogs but sometimes he'll
say you know I'm grateful that you
picked me up early or you know I'm
grateful that I finally understand
adjectives you know so it's there's a
great quote that says it's not granted
it's not joy that makes us grateful it's
gratitude that makes us joyful and it's
by a Jesuit brother a Jesuit priest and
I guess I was just amazed to find that
bubble up so strongly in the research
it's life changing
the next phase here is also to become
grateful for what it is that you do have
so if you're starting to try to create
change in your life you want to make
sure that you're really focusing on what
it is that you do have in your life so
that you feel an energy of gratitude and
an energy of gratitude can really open
you up to this incredible capacity to
feel more energized to feel more happy
in any given moment where you feel like
oh I don't have what I need or I'm not
supported or things aren't working out
the simple step here is to just say I am
grateful for what I do have and let me
look at me say I'm grateful for what I
do have we create more of what we want
and the energy of gratitude opens our
heart and it expands our energy and it
makes us a much more wonderful loving
person to be around and with that loving
energy we begin to attract more into our
life and so we want to really make sure
that that energy of gratitude is a very
pinnacle part of this group this miracle
worker process which is that we stay
committed and open to what it is that we
are here to receive and we stay
committed and grateful for what it is
that we have and so you can begin today
just by making a gratitude list and
focus on it in there's so many moments
when I think oh my god I can't believe I
have to do this or I can't prove enough
to get to that and and then I just think
about what I'm grateful for and it just
spins me immediately out of the crazy
chaos and back into a central place of
love and so I think that this is a
really valuable tool for you to begin to
use regularly and it's an active tool
throughout the book make us miracles if
you have to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or that would be like a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details